The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: And I think we're
about ready to get started.
So welcome, folks,
for lecture number two
of Fundamentals of Photovoltaics
focused on the solar resource.
What I wanted to
do to get everybody
in the mood of
thinking about the sun
is pass around a few balls.
So this is really a, to limber
you all up, but b-- whoop.
[LAUGHTER]
There we go.
All right.
Don't let it fall.
There you go.
I know Ashley's got solid hands.
All right.
Here's one.
Pass that around as well.
We'll get a few
more there, there,
and lastly, right up the middle.
There you go.
OK.
So today's lecture is really
about the solar resource.
And as we go through,
it kind of helps
to have a sphere in your
hands since oftentimes we
perceive the world as being
flat-- no fault of our own.
Locally, one can approximate
it as a flat body.
That's certainly a
good possibility.
You wouldn't mind passing these
out to your friends as well?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
PROFESSOR: Thanks.
But in reality,
if we really want
to understand the
solar resource,
we really have to begin
understanding or thinking
in terms of spheres and in terms
of circles or, in most cases,
ellipses.
And so we're going to dive
into the solar resource.
Before we really dive in in
detail into the solar resource,
I wanted to give you
feedback to your surveys.
So you did a background
assessment survey, a census,
if you will, and filled out a
number of questions last class
about your backgrounds.
And I wanted to provide
you the feedback,
the consolidated information,
because it's really telling
about who your colleagues are.
This right here is a little
bit of a snapshot of expertise
and current career trajectory.
So the self-defined
expertise in the bottom left
is really, I think, the
most telling parameter.
For the undergrads here,
you may define yourself
by your major today, but
when you graduate and go on
to grad school, you might, say,
for example, do your undergrad
in physics and then do
your graduate school
in mechanical
engineering, but still
consider yourself a
physicist at heart.
And so that's why I asked
this question here--
what is your self-defined
expertise-- because there
are several graduate students
who have changed fields,
if you will, from undergrad
to graduate school.
Most people in the
audience, by and large,
consider themselves engineers--
either material science
engineers or
mechanical engineers.
Chemistry is strong as well.
And then we have about 10
different departments here
represented.
And that's really cool.
It's going to manifest
itself in the class projects.
And you'll see the diversity
of different inputs
and perspectives
from your colleagues.
The degree in progress--
undergrad/grad
is about split 1/3 2/3
undergrad and grad.
ASP is Advanced Studies
Program, so these
are folks coming in from
industry who are actually here
in the classroom.
Some of your
colleagues in the class
are folks who are in
industry and perhaps
have real world PV experience.
Several of the people
here in the class,
as well, have
gained-- how do we say
it-- have gained expertise
in solar with their hobbies,
with their work.
Some have installed
solar panels.
Other ones have done research
or are doing research in solar.
So it's a pretty diverse group.
And some are, as well,
members of the solar car
team, which is rolling out its
new model in a few days' time.
In terms of learning
methods, it was pretty well
split between hands-on
labs, field trips,
and guest lectures.
And I'll get back to
that in a few slides.
In terms of class
project interest,
there was a strong
interest in working
with pre-established projects,
so we've listened to that.
This is pretty consistent
with previous years.
And so we have several
pre-prepared class projects
ready for you.
And a few of you had an interest
in the self-design project.
I'd like to talk to you.
I'd like to begin developing
those ideas as soon
as possible so that when
we start assembling teams,
if you do have a strong
idea for class project,
we can begin crafting that
and molding that starting now.
So please come up and
have a chat with me
after class or during office
hours or during recitation.
These are your learning
objectives defined by you.
And they range-- I tried to
give it some continuum spectrum
from natural sciences
to social sciences
and engineering in the middle.
And obviously, this is more
of a loop than a linear line,
but bear with me.
There was a strong
interest in fundamentals.
And that certainly, I think,
what the core of the class
is about or at least the
first third of the class.
Going in terms of
size of the bubble,
these are the
number of people who
listed a particular topic as
of great interest to them.
Economics and market, systems
and grid, current technologies,
and emerging technologies.
And so listening to
all of this, we have,
or we are in the process of
preparing for you some guest
lectures and field trips based
on this feedback right here.
We have already
lined up a field trip
to a local PV research
laboratory that
produces modules like this
one right here only much, much
bigger and has strong
collaboration with existing
companies, startup
companies, in the area
as well as more
established companies.
So that'll be a lot of fun.
And we're currently
in the process
of arranging other
field trips and guest
lectures to match this feedback
right here, so thank you.
We'll mold the course, shape it,
craft it to fit your interests.
So to hop into
the solar resource
and without further ado,
the subject of today
and the motivation
for wearing this tie
is really the solar
resource, the sun.
This is where it all starts.
If we're to understand
PV, photovoltaics,
the conversion of
sunlight into electricity,
it starts from the sun.
And so spending some good
time thinking about the sun
is really, really important.
And it will avoid the
embarrassing situation--
how many of you have been at a
shopping center, walking along,
and a little child is
asking his parent, Dad,
why is the sky blue?
Or why is the such and such?
And the answers
you'll hear just make
you want to tear your ears
out, say, my goodness.
And so part of this is
just general knowledge.
It's getting a feel for
the world and the universe
and asking those questions again
that the little children will
ask but we forget to ask as we
move on with our lives, right?
OK.
So moving forward, the
learning objectives for today
are these right here.
By the end of the
lecture-- and hopefully,
you already have a good sense
of this based on your readings
already.
I'll quiz you on that
second-- verbally.
We want to be able to quantify
the available solar resource
relative to human energy
needs and other fuel sources.
We want to recognize
and plot air mass zero
and air mass 1.5 solar
spectra and describe
the physical origins.
We want to describe how
solar insulation maps--
these are solar resource
maps, in other words, how
much sunlight is available.
And we want to be able to
estimate a solar resource
amount locally at a
specific spot on the planet.
We want to list the causes of
variation and intermittency
of the solar resource
and quantify their time
constant in magnitude.
In other words, we want
to be able to discern
what are the big effects
and what are the ones that
don't really matter.
We want to be able to
estimate the land area needed
to provide sufficient solar
resource for a project,
whether it's a house, a car,
a village, a country, a world.
And a lot of this will be
on your homework assignment,
so we'll give you the
tools here, but then ask
you to address those questions.
And for those of
you who have already
picked up your p-set number one,
you'll see relevant questions.
Where is this?
Does anybody recognize
this right here?
If I start rambling
off names, what city
has Pennsylvania Avenue,
Independence Ave?
AUDIENCE: Washington, DC.
PROFESSOR: Washington, DC.
This is right outside of the
National Air and Space Museum.
What this little girl here
is pointing to is the sun.
And then we have Mercury, Venus,
Earth, Mars, and so forth.
So it's essentially a
solar system to scale.
As you walk out of the
Air and Space Museum
and walk down the street, you'll
be passing the different bodies
in our solar system.
And so just as a
quick little review
to kind of get us situated
and to ask the questions
that little kiddies
might ask us,
how far is it from
the earth to the sun?
AUDIENCE: 93 million miles.
PROFESSOR: About
100 million miles.
Yeah.
93 million miles.
Plus or minus somewhere in
the range of maybe a percent
or so, a few percent
depending on what time of year
we are since we're in a little
bit of an elliptical orbit.
Good.
So that's the
distance to the sun.
It would be about 150
million kilometers.
How long does it take light
to travel that distance?
AUDIENCE: Eight minutes.
PROFESSOR: About eight minutes,
eight and a third minutes,
right?
So it takes a little bit
for the light to reach us.
Good.
Some more questions-- how
far are the other planets
in our solar system to the sun,
going in order from Mercury
out?
It's to get us situated here.
If we are, at any
point, planning
on throwing up satellites
and sending them
with other planets,
this is a good thing
to kind of keep in
the back of our minds.
So if we define an
astronomical unit--
not in terms of
our national debt,
but in terms of the distance
from the earth to the sun--
that's an astronomical unit.
Mercury would be
somewhere around 0.4.
Venus 0.7.
Mars 1.5.
So that's all kind of in
our neighborhood, right?
And then from Mars to
Jupiter is a bit of a jump.
It goes from 1.5 to 5.
Then from Jupiter to
Saturn is 10-- well, sorry.
10 is the distance
from Saturn to the Sun.
And then 30 and then 40.
Sorry, 10, 20, 30, 40.
So it goes-- Jupiter's
5, Saturn 10.
Uranus would be 20.
Neptune 30.
Pluto 40.
Pluto, planet, sort of.
So it's easy to remember those
numbers because it goes 5, 10,
20-- that's just essentially
a sequence of doubling--
and then 10, 20, 30, 40.
I'm giving you
approximate numbers here,
but that's something just
to keep in mind all in terms
of astronomical units.
So in case a little kid
comes up and asks you,
you can spit out the answer.
Let's talk about the sun.
This is just a review of
our readings right here.
This was a
representation of the sun
and the Earth moving around.
And what is solstice
and equinox?
What do those refer to?
What is the equinox?
AUDIENCE: Equal amounts
of light and dark.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, equal
amounts of light and dark
throughout pretty
much all the world
except if you're really
standing on the tippy top
and the bottom.
So equal amount
of light and dark
throughout the world
on that particular day.
So the day and the night have
the same amount of length.
If you move over to
this region right here,
this would be a region of our
northern hemisphere summer,
southern hemisphere, winter.
Over here, vice versa.
And the solstice would be?
AUDIENCE: The shortest
day of the year.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So the shortest or the
longest day of the year,
depending on what
side you're on.
So in the northern
hemisphere, the June solstice
would be the summer solstice.
For us, it would
be the longest day.
And if you're in the
southern hemisphere,
it would be the shortest day.
Depending on what
time zone you're in,
there might be a variation
of one day hither to.
Good.
OK.
And what is this?
What are the seasons caused by?
What is this kind
of tilt right here?
What is that called?
AUDIENCE: Declination angle.
PROFESSOR: Declination angle.
And approximately
how much is that?
AUDIENCE: 23 and 1/2.
PROFESSOR: 23 and 1/2.
23.45.
Yeah, so 23 1/2 degrees.
Good.
OK.
And we can visualize all
of this on the PV CD-ROM
on the website.
So this was part of
your assigned reading.
And here's the earth
going around the sun
in this representation.
Likewise, if you want to
take one of your balls
and just kind of imagine being
on one of those surfaces,
you see the diurnal
rotation here.
It's spinning around its axis.
And as well, the
seasonal variation as it
spins around the sun.
That's important for a
number of reasons, right?
That will determine how
much sunlight is normally
incident on the planet.
If you are normally incident,
if you're at this exact spot
right here, you're receiving
the sunlight full on.
But if you're up here
somewhere, your surface normal
is some vector
pointing out like that.
You're only going to be
receiving the cosine theta
of that amount of sun.
So if you're an extreme
example, if you're right here,
you're not going to get any.
But if you're in
this part right here,
you're going to get cosine
of 0, which would be 1.
So you get the
full amount of sun.
And likewise, as you move
through the angles here.
So it's important to understand
what the relative angle is
between our surface normal and
the vector pointing at the sun.
That varies as a
function of season.
It varies as a function
of time of day.
And obviously, over
the entire earth,
you can define the
precise amount of sunlight
coming in, the precise
solar resource,
by a series of trig formula.
It gets pretty complex.
And this website will
actually walk you through it
if you're so interested.
Now this is all review
since folks have all done
the background ready, right?
All done the background reading.
I expect you to before class.
Let me ask you a few
trickier questions just
to see if our creative
juices are really moving
at this early time of day.
When would be the
shortest day of the year?
Let's start there.
The shortest day of the year
is approximately December 22,
right?
In the solstice.
When is the latest sunrise and
when is the earliest sunset?
You might need to pick
up your little ball
and rotate it around.
Does anybody have
even just a gut sense?
Would it be on the solstice?
How many people think it's going
to be exactly on the solstice?
Let's see.
Earliest sunset--
how many people
think that the
earliest sunset's going
to be a little bit
before the solstice?
How many people think a
little bit after the solstice?
I know people don't really know.
The reality is that the earliest
sunset would be a little bit
before the solstice here,
and the latest sunrise
would be a little bit
after the solstice.
And it flips in summertime.
It would be, let's see,
the earliest sunrise
and the latest sunset before
and after the solstice
respectively.
OK.
And you can think
about that in terms
of what is the solar noon.
The solar noon is when the
sun this is directly overhead
relative to our
chronological noon, which
is, I would say, less
dependent on the specific angle
of the earth relative
to the sun as it
moves around this trajectory.
Let's get more into
that in recitation.
I sense since there wasn't
much traction there I
don't want to dwell.
OK.
Good, good, good.
Let's think a little
bit more in terms
of the trajectory
of the sun later on
as we move through some of
the introductory material.
I don't want to dwell too much.
I want to give a
little bit of review
since I'm sensing that not
everybody did the readings.
I expect you to do
the readings, folks.
So let's keep with me here.
So a touch of history,
since that was asked for.
It was requested.
I decided to launch a
little bit into a history
of the study of the sun.
Philosophers, going back to what
I suppose most would consider
early India, studied the sun.
There were some writings of
some of the earlier philosophers
that were recorded.
Some have interpreted
these writings
as being indicative of,
perhaps, heliocentric models.
These are poetry, folks.
It's a very different
style of communication
than what we have today
of technical writing,
so it's difficult for us
to discern, or difficult
for me, at least, to discern
when I read the lines verbatim
if this is really
somebody thinking
about the heliocentric
model or whether this
is somebody just
describing the universe
in the best of their abilities.
I would say the real beginnings
of heliocentric models
began in the third century
Before the Common Era
and the notions of
interstellar distances
estimated in a similar
manner to what we just
walked through today, right?
Estimating the distance
between the earth and the sun
and then using that as a
measure or yardstick with which
to measure the distances
to the other planets
began somewhere
during that time.
Likewise, these writings
of old made their way
to the Middle East.
And in the 10th
and 11th centuries
of the Common Era,
the Middle East,
the Arab world is really where
science and technology was at.
And these days, I
mean, Europe was still
largely mired in
the Middle Ages,
starting to emerge
in a few places.
But by and large, the
carriers of civilization
in the Western world
were really centered
and in some of the Arab
cities in the Middle East.
And al-Biruni, in
particular, was very avid
at applying methods of
astronomical observation,
in particular to aid travel,
but in the process, discovering
a thing or two about
our known universe.
And of course, finally,
Johannes Kepler in Europe,
once it starts to emerge
from the Middle Ages,
with really taking observation
some other scientists, who
very carefully plotted
out the position
of the different
bodies, he came up
with some of the
mathematical models that
describe the motion of the
planets through the skies
and is largely credited
with developing
a series of laws that define
interplanetary motion.
So a couple of
interesting things to note
is that international
collaboration
was really essential.
These ideas didn't
develop in isolation.
They were flowing
throughout the world.
It's important to know
that many of the scientists
were well-traveled
polyglots, meaning
they spoke different languages.
And that's how they were
able to interpret the texts
and readings of other people.
And it's also to note
that parallel astronomical
developments were happening in
other regions of the world--
the Far East, Mesoamerica,
and so forth, right?
And so obviously, there may
have been some communication--
I would say rather
sparse-- between especially
with the Far East.
But there was a fair
amount of communication
between these regions here.
And you can imagine writings
or ideas traveling from word
of mouth along trade routes.
So there was some communication.
So back to our
learning objectives.
Today, we're about to quantify
the available solar resource
relative to human energies
and other fuel sources.
So let's do that.
We'll jump right into
one of the slides
that I showed you last time.
This is in terms
of terawatts av.
Terawatts is a unit of
power, a very big one.
"Tera" is 10 to the 12.
And you can see
here the resource
of the sun relative to the
wind energy resource base
relative to human energy needs.
If we just consider the resource
falling on the earth's surface,
as opposed to that falling
on the outer atmosphere,
there's a little
bit of a discount.
But we're still very large
compared to human energy use.
And if we redefine our
units from terawatts
into HECs, which are Human
Energy Consumptions, defined
in, say, 2050, where
one HEC is the average,
let's say, energy
burn rate of 2050,
you can see here
that these numbers
are a few orders of
magnitude larger than what
our human needs are.
So if you were able
to capture only 1%
of all of the solar resource
falling on the earth's crust,
we would be actually
in pretty good shape.
And 1% of the total land
area on the earth's crust--
I believe somewhere between
1% and 2% of the United States
is covered in asphalt
right now for roads.
So this could be on houses,
on rooftops, on buildings,
and so forth.
We wouldn't necessarily
have to exclusively repave
virgin farmland
with solar panels.
So going back to quantifying the
solar power, we have our sun.
We're going to
start by quantifying
the solar resource by assuming
that the sun is a black body.
The same way that hot
objects emit light-- say,
for example, when you
turn up your stove
and you have a very warm
glow coming out of it--
the sun is as well a hot
body, a black body, sorry.
Very hot as well, somewhere
around 6,000 Kelvin.
And the total radiated power is
given by Stefan Boltzmann's law
here in the following way
where we have temperature
to the fourth and
the temperature
is somewhere around
6,000 Kelvin.
And so we have this
power being radiated out
at the surface of the sun.
And then, as it travels outward,
it becomes, you could say,
diluted in effect.
Because the total surface area
of that sphere is increasing,
obviously as r squared.
And so by the time that that
light reaches the earth,
it's only a very
small cross section,
or very small solid
angle to be more precise,
of the sun's surface that is
radiating directly at the earth
right here because this, in the
absence of scattering centers
in the universe that
might reflect or bounce
the light back toward the earth.
And you can calculate
the total power incident
on the earth by that
simple formula right there.
What is the radius of the earth?
Again, one of these
simple numbers
you should kind of
having your head.
6,370 kilometers, somewhere
in that order, right?
And so you can begin
estimating here the total power
and the order of magnitude.
It's going to be tiny
compared to the total power
that the sun is
radiating thankfully,
or else we'd be
pretty hot right now.
So the average power
coming from the sun
on the surface of
the outer atmosphere
is around 1,366 watts
per square meter.
Who's heard of 1,366 before?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
You've heard about it?
All right.
You know where the
number comes from now.
It's pretty wonky.
1366 is a startup
company, a spin-off
of MIT focused on solar energy.
OK.
And so that's at the equinox,
which we just learned
is occurring somewhere
around March 21,
September 21-- coming up soon.
Celebration.
The ratio of the surface
areas of the spheres
is really something to
keep in mind right there.
OK.
So we've quantified
the available resource
relative to human energy needs.
Now we have to come
up with some language
that we use to
describe the sunlight
moving through the
atmosphere of the earth
and reaching the surface
of the earth, right?
So we're going to use
what's called the air mass
convention or AM convention.
AM stands for Air Mass.
Even without knowing much
about how the light is absorbed
or how to quantify
it mathematically,
we can assume that our
atmosphere contains molecules.
It contains particulate matter.
And that's going to interact
with the light in some ways.
Probably either going
to absorb or scatter it.
And so as the light passes
through our atmosphere,
there's going to
be some absorption.
And the greater the distance,
the greater the optical path
length through the atmosphere,
the more absorption and more
scattering there will be.
And so we use air
mass, or AM convention,
to define the path length
or the path distance
through the atmosphere.
AM0 would mean the
outer atmosphere.
AM1 would be essentially
just going straight through,
normal incidence so that the
direction of the trajectory
of the light is parallel
to the surface normal
of the earth at that location.
And then air mass
1.5 and so forth
is as we increase the
angle of the entry of light
relative to the surface normal.
So in other words,
as we go further
from the equator to
northern latitudes
that air mass number is
going to go up, up, up.
OK.
We'll explain it
with a few graphs
and figures and a few slides.
So we have our
atmospheric absorption.
When we just glance at the earth
in these beautiful pictures
taken from outer space, we can
see very obviously the clouds
present.
And more importantly,
if we were to zoom
in on one of these
regions right here,
we would see this
bluish hue coming
from our atmosphere, which
is scattering preferentially
the shorter
wavelengths of light.
And more importantly,
this radius right here
is somewhere on the order
of 6,370 kilometers.
And this thin atmospheric
shell in on the order of 30.
Right?
So that's why you
don't really see
too much of a ring around the
planet from this distance.
So the atmospheric effects,
let's try to bend them
into discrete buckets.
This is a simplification,
but it helps us gain
a foothold in understanding.
And then from there, we
can make our understanding
a bit more complex.
So we have incoming solar
radiation coming from here.
We have a number now that's
342 watts per square meter.
Why is that number so
much lower than the 1,366
that we were just talking about?
AUDIENCE: Particles in
the air and pollution
in the atmosphere.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So this is meant
to be an average
over the entire day at one fixed
point along the ground, right?
So as we're rotating around, we
have at least half of the day
normally when we
don't have sunlight.
And then there's, I would
say, the cosine theta angle
is not 1 at all times.
It's very rarely 1.
And so this is a bit of a
discounted incoming solar
radiation, essentially a
time-averaged solar radiation
for a given patch of the
planet over a typical day.
And so we have a variety
of processes here.
We have reflection
off of clouds.
That's pretty clear
to see from here.
It looks nice and white.
We have some absorbed
by the atmosphere,
typically in a rotational or
vibrational modes of molecules
up in the outer atmosphere,
sometimes by particulate matter
as well.
And then we have
the amount that's
absorbed here by the surface,
of course, reflected as well.
And so the amount that's
incident on the surface
or coming down to us
is what we can actually
use to make solar energy.
And this is an average, right?
Because sometimes the cloud
cover is a lot greater.
And for that
particular day, we will
have a lot less resource
striking the ground
at a given time.
This over here, this is
all mostly infrared, right?
Where this is visible coming
in, once the light gets absorbed
and then gets
re-emitted, it usually
gets re-emitted in
the longer wavelength
light or the infrared light.
And this is the stuff that
gets blocked by or absorbed
by greenhouse gases and then
re-emitted equiangularly.
And some of it makes its way
back to the earth, right?
OK.
So air mass, let's
define that so
that we have a common
language that we
can use to describe the solar
resource from place to place.
So again, this is the sun.
This is the surface right here.
And let's imagine that the angle
between the incident sunlight
and the surface normal is 0
such that the cosine theta
term is 1.
Air mass here at this
point, at this point
on the surface of the
earth, is going to be AM 1.
So we call it air mass 1 if
the sun is literally directly
overhead.
What did we learn about the
declination angle of the earth?
It's about 23 and
1/2 degrees, right?
How far north are we?
What is our latitude
here in Boston?
AUDIENCE: 41.
PROFESSOR: 41, 42ish, right?
So let's for simplicity say that
here in Boston, our latitude
of Boston Logan Airport is
approximately 41 degrees north.
And let's say that the
declination of our planet
is approximately
23 and 1/2 degrees.
So what would be the angle
of the sun in the sky
if you were to lie on your back
in the middle of the summer
solstice and the middle
of the winter solstice
and you're lying straight
on your back looking up
at solar noon, what would the
angle of the sun in the sky
be relative to the
surface normal?
How far south would the sun be?
Imagine that this is 0
degrees and that's 90, right?
So relative to this
angle right here,
where would the
sun be in the sky?
Why don't you turn to your
neighbor right now and discuss?
On the summer solstice,
the winter solstice,
come up with some
set of angles there.
All right, folks.
What do we come up with?
This is our little human
being, you, in Boston.
This is south, and that's north.
And we're at the solar
noon in the winter solstice
in the summer solstice.
So here's you.
This is directly above.
So I would say if you're
lying on your back
and looking straight
up, that's the surface
normal of the earth.
In the summer, at
solar noon, the sun
would be at what angle
relative to the surface
normal of the earth?
AUDIENCE: 17 and 1/2.
PROFESSOR: 17 and 1/2,
somewhere around there.
And how did you get that number?
Subtract those two, right?
So you get 41 minus 23 and 1/2.
You're somewhere around 17,
18, somewhere around there.
So we'll call it 18
degrees in summer,
again, relative to
the surface normal.
And in wintertime, what
does that work out to be?
AUDIENCE: 64 and 1/2.
PROFESSOR: 64 and 1/2.
Similar logic, right?
So we'll call it 65
degrees in winter.
Good.
So what does that work out
to be in terms of air mass
for winter and summer?
Quick engineering
approximation, I'm
going to say that, in summer,
it's approximate air mass 1,
but you can calculate
it real quick.
Somebody with a calculator
want to plug those in?
AUDIENCE: And
roughly 2 in winter.
PROFESSOR: And
All right?
OK.
We're going to get into
scattering of light
in next lecture actually.
And we'll see why that
matters in terms of especially
of getting sunburned
since the shorter
wavelengths, the ultraviolet,
are more sensitive to the path
length.
OK.
Good.
Very good.
So we have pretty
much a gut sense
now of where the
sun is in the sky.
And as it moves from summer to
winter, from our perspective,
it follows a little
bit of a, I would
say, sinusoidal path, right?
It stays in summer for a
long period of time up here.
And then it moves pretty quickly
down here and stays here.
So versus time, the angle
of the sun in the sky
is following a sine curve,
or cosine curve if you will.
Right?
And so right now, the sun is
actually close to the middle.
We're in September 13.
The solstice is coming
up in a week's time.
And so the slope
of that sine curve
is at a maximum right about now.
And so that the amount of
time that the day will change
in length is changing
at its greatest point
right now in the year.
And so you really
begin to notice it
if you start paying
attention or if you
go to weather.com
and start looking up
how long is today's
day going to last,
when is the sunset tomorrow.
I don't know about you
folks, but I like to cycle.
And when I'm doing
my evening rides,
I'm noticing it now
that I have to start
earlier and earlier if I want
to put in, say, 30 or 40 miles.
I'm not going to be able
to make it home in time.
So that's the sun
and how it relates
to you in your daily lives.
We're going to get back
to this in a minute,
so keep this in mind.
Don't let it out of your RAM.
Let's talk about the actual
solar spectrum for a minute.
This is the sunlight intensity
in some very real units.
We'll get to that in a minute.
But think of this in terms
sort of like the total amount
of power in a given bandwidth.
So the wavelength right
here-- or the power density
in the bandwidth.
The wavelength is the
wavelength of light.
Shown for your convenience
here is the visible spectrum.
That's what our
eye-- mostly what
our eye-- is able to
detect in this wavelength
range right here.
And the sun is emitting
over a much broader range
of wavelengths.
It's emitting following
a black body emission
source at 6,000 Kelvin.
And that's in this
very difficult
to see green line right there.
Air mass 0 spectrum looks like
this, this red line right here.
And again, let me remind
you that the air mass
0 is the light that's falling
on the outer atmosphere.
There is no earth
atmospheric absorption yet.
Why do we have these
little lines here?
Do you see it's not
a perfect black body.
We have some-- I'll give you
a hint-- absorption lines.
Where is that light
being absorbed?
Is it the ether between
the earth and the sun?
No.
There's no ether between
the earth and sun.
Where is that light
being absorbed?
AUDIENCE: Hydrogen
ions and stuff?
PROFESSOR: In the
sun itself, right?
So these are absorption
events occurring
in the solar atmosphere.
And now, if we do
air mass 1 or 1.5--
let's push it up a little
bit from air mass 0--
this is now passing
through an angle
of somewhere around 60 degrees.
Now what do we have?
We have several absorption
lines occurring, right?
And these correspond to
absorption events where?
AUDIENCE: In the
earth's atmosphere.
PROFESSOR: In the
Exactly.
And so we can attribute each of
these little absorption lines
here to a particular--
usually it's
a molecule in the
earth's atmosphere.
Note the sensitivity of
the human in black right
here and how well-matched
it is to the air mass
1, air mass 1.5 spectrum.
That's pretty cool.
OK.
So there you have the spectrum.
Let's get to these units of
power density per bandwidth
for a second.
The way to think
about those units
is as follows-- kilowatts
per meter squared.
OK, I get that.
It's the amount of power
falling on a unit area.
Per micron, the reason
it's normalized per micron
is because the wavelength
units right here is in microns.
And if you take the
product of the two,
it makes it pretty easy to
calculate the total power
density, right?
So if you want to calculate the
power density, the total watts
per square meter,
falling on the earth,
say, between 0.5
and 1 micron, you
can calculate the
total amount of power
by multiplying one
versus the other.
So that's why they're in
this weird unit right here.
It's to help you
perform calculations
like the ones you'll
do in your homework,
like the ones you'll do for
your class project and so forth.
And it strikes a little bit odd
the first time you look at it,
but it begins making sense.
And you're appreciative
of it after a while.
There are standard spectra.
They're standard
reference spectra.
Sure, you can go
outside and using
some form of spectrophotometer.
You can measure the incident
solar radiation and map
out the spectral irradiance
as a function of wavelength.
In terms of the planning
or communicating
with other scientists, we
typically refer to standards.
We use common yardsticks,
common metrics.
And that facilitates
communication,
avoids ambiguity,
avoids misunderstanding.
And so these standards
right here, these ASTMs,
refer to the
particular standards
that are used for
those solar spectra.
And in your supporting
online material,
at the very end of the
lecture slides online,
we go into some more
detail regarding that
for those who are interested.
So again, these little
absorption lines
here correspond to specific
atmospheric events,
interactions of that
particular wavelength of light
with some molecule
usually in the atmosphere.
We can, as well, have
generalized attenuation due
to other scattering mechanisms.
Notice right here in the short
wavelengths what's happening.
From the red to the
blue, this light
is particularly effective.
We have a sharp drop in
the shorter wavelengths.
And it grows sharper the
shorter in wavelength you go.
So the attenuation due to
passing through the atmosphere
grows or increases the
shorter in wavelength you go.
And this is a process generally
called Rayleigh scattering.
And there's a wavelength
to the fourth dependence.
So as you go shorter and
shorter in wavelength,
the likelihood or probability
of scattering will increase.
Why is that pertinent to us?
Well, now you can
answer that little child
who walks up to you in the
shopping mall and says,
why is the sky blue?
You say, well, there is this
elastic scattering mechanism
of electromagnetic
radiation whereby
in a broad spectral event,
such as the sun, black body
emission, we have the
shorter wavelengths that
are scattered more.
And that's why when we
look away from the sun,
in the other direction, we see
those shorter wavelengths that
are scattered back to us.
That is pertinent
for two reasons.
A, it makes the sky look blue.
Secondly, it's not only the
short wavelengths in blue light
that we're worried about, but
also the ultraviolet radiation.
Right?
So even on a cloudy day, if
there are a few open patches
and you can get scattered
light coming in,
you can still get sunburned.
And secondly, there is
a very strong dependence
on the path length, the optical
path length, the air mass,
right?
So if you go further north
in latitudes, where your air
mass increases,
right-- because now,
if you think about
the atmosphere
as being kind of a flat.
Just giving you an
approximation for minute.
If you think of the
earth being flat
and the atmosphere
of being flat,
now the path length in
winter is much, much greater
than the path length in summer.
Same sun, just
different path length.
You're much more likely to
get sunburned in the summer
than you are in winter
because the path length is
a lot shorter and the amount
of short wavelength ultraviolet
radiation that will
be scattered away
is going to be less in
the summer than in winter.
That's also why if you go
south latitude, for example,
from here to, say, Miami, your
incidence of getting sunburned
is a lot greater, a lot
more than the total increase
of the visible portion
of the spectrum.
So the sun might not look
that different to you,
but your incidence of sunburn
events goes up quite a bit.
And that is due to
Rayleigh scattering.
And now, by this
point, the little child
has already run crying
back to the parent.
But you have a full
satisfaction of knowing
how the universe around
you is put together.
And that actually was
a pretty deep problem.
It took a long time for at
least European scientists
to crack that nut and figure
out what was going on.
Describe how solar
insulation maps are made
and use them to estimate
the local solar resource.
So we have metrology.
We have techniques
that we can use
to measure the amount of
sunlight that is out there.
And now we want to apply those
in some systematic fashion
to measure the average solar
resource around the planet,
including the oceans, and
then use that information
to estimate later on the
land area needed, or the size
of the array, or
how many cells we're
going to have to string together
based on the solar resource
locally.
So how are these
insulation maps made,
these maps that we'll use as
engineers to size our systems?
First off, let me
define insolation.
This is not insulation, as in
stuff you put around the house
to keep the heat from going out.
This is insolation with
an "o," a shorthand
for incoming solar radiation.
Insolation at the top there.
It's typically given in units
of energy per unit area per unit
time, so kilowatt
hours-- that's energy--
per meter squared per day.
And it's helpful when designing
or projecting these PV systems.
And it's affected by a bunch
of stuff, which we'll get
to over the next few slides.
So we can measure
insolation from the ground.
That's a surefire way to do it.
This right here
is a pyranometer.
Pyro, fire, sun.
Ano, on top of.
So anode/cathode.
Cata, under.
Ano, above.
Catatonic, under.
Right?
OK.
So pyranometer.
So it's basically measuring
the sun above, right?
Measuring the sunlight above.
This is a full hemisphere
measuring the sunlight
coming in from all angles.
There's a small little
sensor right here.
It's lying flat.
And that glass is essentially
allowing the light
from different angles
to get into the sensor.
And this is a very narrow,
solid angle of the sky.
It's probably just
looking at the sun,
or in a particular direction
rather, plus or minus 2 and 1/2
degrees in either direction.
So it's a very limited
solid angle of the sky.
This one over here would
be more appropriate, say,
for a flat panel that's
receiving scattered light
coming in at all angles.
This one over here would be
more appropriate for a tracking
system, especially a
concentrator system that
has optics that only
accept light in from a very
limited solid angle.
So imagine you have a lens that
has to have like incident to it
to focus it on the right spot.
And if the sun moves in the
wrong spot or the-- put it
another way-- if the lens
is in the wrong position
relative to the incident
solar radiation,
the light is being focused
off of the solar cell.
And it doesn't
produce any power.
So this is a system
that's used for measuring
the direct solar
spectrum, which will
be useful for calculating the
total output from concentrator
systems.
And this pyranometer
over here is
useful for flat panel systems.
And we can also measure
the total amount
of incident solar radiation,
total amount of insolation,
from the sky using
satellite imagery.
This is an example
of a measurement.
And this right here is
insolation, average insolation,
from 0 to 550 watts
per square meter taken
from a NASA satellite with
the NASA Earth Observatory.
Very cool website, great
place to spend a Friday night
if you don't have plans.
Just log on here, and
bunches of maps from snow
cover, to population density,
to CO2 being emitted,
to wildfires around
the planet-- anything
that a satellite can
measure, they're measuring.
And the insolation
value is one of them.
And so we have data
from various points.
This is the
insolation in January.
So in January, it's the
Southern Hemisphere's summer,
the Northern
Hemisphere's winter.
And as a result, we have
less insolation up north.
We're in the blues.
And the Southern Hemisphere
is more in the reds.
And of course, the
tide turns in July.
We have our summer and
the Southern Hemisphere
has their winter.
And the poor folks here in
Antarctica have nothing.
So a couple of things
to note just already
straight off the
bat, we're noticing
that there's, in general,
higher insolation
near the equator, the
equator passing right
through here approximately.
Fun fact-- small city up
there in the north of Brazil,
there's a soccer field
that is half in the north
and half in the south.
That's neither here nor there.
We have rainforests up here
in the north of Brazil,
Central Africa, and
here in Southeast Asia.
And even when the sun
is directly overhead,
those clouds are preventing
some of the sunlight
from getting in.
And that's why right
at the equator itself,
we typically have
less insolation
than we do in the
tropics, say, Tropic
of Capricorn, Tropic of Cancer.
Tropic of Capricorn
running straight
through Sao Paulo,
Brazil, Tropic of Cancer
running through Key West.
Just to situate yourselves.
And the Tropics are how
far away from the equator?
Right.
OK.
23 and 1/2.
Good guess.
Good.
So what we're going
to do is now launch
into our next
learning objective,
which is to list the causes
of variation and intermittency
of the solar resource
and quantify the time
constants in magnitudes.
This is really, really,
really, really important.
The other stuff is very
useful from an engineering
point of view from
answering certain questions
in your homework.
This right here is the singular
reason-- one of the singular
reasons-- why solar
doesn't behave
like a regular fossil fuel
source, why solar does not
produce power all the time.
It is variable in terms
of its power output.
Variability generally
refers to the fact
that we can predict it's coming.
It's going to vary, but at least
we can predict it's coming.
Intermittency, while
not a strict definition,
the understanding when
somebody says "intermittency"
or "intermittent power source,"
the impression that it gives
is that it's
unpredictable in terms
of its variability
and its variation.
So we've talked a little
bit about the variation
so far and about the
predictable nature of the sun.
We've talked about how the
sunlight, the solar resource,
varies from summer to winter.
We've talked about how
the solar resource varies
as a function of
latitude, right?
But now, we're going to talk not
only in a little bit more depth
about that and have a few
fun in-class exercises
to get us really grasping
that concept in its entirety,
but also talk about some
sources of intermittency, which
if you have a large amount of
solar contributing to the grid
and it is intermittent, and
you have no way of dealing
with that, you're going to have
fluctuations of energy level
on the grid or power levels
here as a function of time.
And that's not going to be good.
So in terms of the
seasonal variations,
in terms of predicting
the amount coming
from the sun at
a given point-- I
told you it looks a little bit
like a sine, a cosine wave.
And indeed, it does.
You can calculate those values
based on this website right
here.
Just to show you how
nifty and cool it is,
our friends at Arizona State
University, Stuart Bowden
and Christiana Honsberg,
really put in a lot of time
to make this.
You can vary the time
or the day of year
right here for instance.
Right?
And you can see how
the solar resource--
this is the direct radiation,
kilowatts per meter squared.
And this is the time.
So if you take the integral
of the curve right here,
you're going to get what?
Units of--
AUDIENCE: Power.
PROFESSOR: Power.
Power times time is?
AUDIENCE: Energy.
PROFESSOR: Energy.
Energy per unit area, right?
So you're going to
be able to calculate
the total amount of
energy falling on a given
area per day, let's say, right?
So if we look at the size of
this little curve in winter,
the total area under this
is going to be very small.
And that's because the solar
resource is very small.
And the sun rises late
and sets early in winter.
And as we move towards
summer, obviously,
the total amount of the
solar resource increases.
Not only it increases
because of this
that we have at solar noon.
We have less of a path
through the atmosphere.
We have more sunlight
reaching the earth.
We have a total increase of
the amount reaching the earth.
We also have that
cosine theta term here
dictating the
cross-section incident
to that sunlight
coming in increasing.
And so that's driving
this going up.
And we also have a
second fact that the time
of the day, the total duration
of the day, increases,
at least in northern
latitudes here at around 40,
let's say, 41 degrees
north, here in Boston.
And we have because these two
effects a much larger area
underneath that curve.
And so as we go through summer
and now finally to September 13
and back to winter, our solar
resource goes back down again.
So you can calculate it.
You can visualize it.
That's cool.
And we can plot the
total amount of energy
per unit area per day,
essentially the integral
under that curve, as a function
of location around the US,
around the world per
month let's say, right?
So this is January.
This is kilowatt hours
per meter squared per day.
So it's just taking the
integral of the curves measured.
So it's accounting for
cloudy days, which kind of
has a depressive effect.
This is an envelope
function, if you will,
the maximum you could get.
And then, of course,
local weather patterns
will suppress that,
drive it down.
So this is the real map
of the United States.
And you can see in sunnier
areas that are less cloudy, over
here, for example, in
Arizona and New Mexico,
there's a large solar
resource even in January.
Atlanta, which has half of the
number of sunny days per year
as Phoenix does, even as
it's at the same latitude,
is getting about half
the solar resource.
They got a short
end of the stick.
Again, this curve right here is
the envelope function, right?
And off of that, you
can only go down.
You can only decrease the amount
of solar resource actually
arriving at our feet here.
And so this is in January.
And this is all in
the same color scale
here as we move
through the months.
So we'll move from January, to
February, to March, April, May,
June, July, August, September,
October, November, December.
So you can see across
the United States
how the resource is
distributed geographically.
The general trend that as
you go from south to north
you have a decreasing
solar resource holds.
You can also see the influence
of local weather patterns
as well for the same latitude.
So that's pretty nifty.
And another nifty fact, if
you look at the year average
value, annual-- this is the
annual average value-- here
in Boston, we're averaging
around 4.5 kilowatt hours
per meter squared per day.
Phoenix, Arizona can be
upwards of 6 somewhere
in the outskirts.
It's not that bad.
It's only a few
tenths of percent.
It's not that bad,
I tell myself.
I don't believe
it myself either,
but I try to convince myself
of that during winter.
All right.
Let me show you the seasonal
and diurnal variations.
We're increasing the
level of sophistication
as we go along, right?
We've assumed you've
done your readings.
We've started with
some simple examples,
and now we're really
taking it one step further,
which is to introduce
the full 3D model.
And I'm going to do that by use
of this really cool app that's
available here.
Right here.
This is you standing
on the earth.
And you can drag and
pull this around.
You can see there's north,
south, east, and west.
So I'm going to pull
it up a little bit
just to give us a little
bit of perspective.
Still, south is
facing toward us.
North is away.
The sun will rise in the
east and set in the west.
Now, let's say I pull the
date back to September.
So this little tool is so cool
because it recognizes your IP
address and situates you
at the proper latitude,
so we don't have to
touch that at all.
It's approximately right.
We're at 40, yeah,
about 41 degrees.
We're right here in September.
And in terms of time of
day, we can pretty much just
cycle through the time
of day if we like.
We could, for example,
start animation.
Let's see, this is going
very fast right now.
I'm going to slow it down so you
can see the time of day moving
right over here.
And you can see that
relative to our vantage
point on the surface
of the earth,
this little yellow dot here
and this yellow line is tracing
through the path of the sun in
the sky from our perspective.
And so as we go
through the seasons,
I'm going to speed it
up just a little bit
so that we pay more
attention to the position
of this yellow line
and less attention
to the diurnal variations.
We're paying more attention
to the seasonal variations.
I'm going to vary the
seasons by force here.
I'm going to go back to
July or June if I may.
Here we go.
AUDIENCE: What's the blue line?
So you can see it?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So there's a number of
other lines right here,
and they're all
explained very carefully.
There is the hour
of ascension, which
would be prime hour circle.
Yes.
I'd have to go back and
double-check all of this,
but I believe they relate
to would be the sunrise
and sunset of that given day.
Let's see if our
hypothesis is correct.
No, it is not.
That would have to be,
since it is varying
in a systematic way from
January through the summer
and then back to the
winter, I'm imagining
this has something to do
with the direction of the sun
relative to the earth,
right, as it traces
that ellipse through the sky.
So let's pay attention to
that yellow line for a minute.
That's the one I want to attract
everybody's attention to.
Now we're in June, so
in the height of summer.
And relative to this
observer right here,
the sun is further
up in the sky just
like we traced out right there.
And now, as we go
to winter, that line
drops close to the horizon.
So a couple of things happen.
If we look like
this for instance,
now we're looking straight
down on the observer.
In wintertime, the sun
will rise in the southeast,
and it will trace this
arc through the sky
and set in the
southwest over here.
In the summertime,
the sun will rise
almost in the northeast,
slightly north of east, just
slightly north of east.
And that's why if you
have a north-facing window
and you put your little
plant on the window sill,
it'll get a little bit of direct
sunlight early in the morning
and late at night.
Because when the sun is tracing
this part or that part through,
it's tracing the sky.
So it's worth sitting down
with one of these plots,
toying around with it,
getting accustomed to it,
and understanding really
how the sun traces its arc
throughout the sky relative
to our position right
here on the earth.
If we shift this
further up north,
really interesting
things begin to happen.
So for example, my
wife is in Sweden.
If we go to her hometown right
here in the middle summertime
at the solstice,
you can see the sun
traces this awesome
route from north
to north barely
leaving the horizon.
If we look at, again,
from the perspective
of the little creature
here, that yellow arc
is really close to the horizon.
Maybe it goes up
about that high,
but it continues going
all the way to the north.
And if you keep going
north, it will never
set during the middle of summer.
It'll just be
light all the time.
And you can see here it
just traces that orbit right
around there.
It's all trig, folks.
We can do it.
We can sit down, and we can work
through the equations by hand.
I did that once.
It took me a long time.
I didn't learn that much.
I would instead advise you to
go to one of these simulations
right here, but to understand
all the inputs into it,
all the different
components, the fact
that the earth is moving
around the sun as a declination
angle, seasonal
variations, and so forth.
Very useful tool.
You have the website
link right here.
And yeah.
So from this tool-- actually,
one last tiny, tiny thing.
From this tool right here, we
can understand why-- OK, this
is a real stretch.
And forgive me, social
scientists in the room,
for doing this, but I have to
project a little bit of science
onto human behavior.
How far west is Madrid from GMT?
Madrid, Spain?
It's 3 degrees west
of the Great Meridian.
So the line that divides the
East and the West Hemispheres
is 3 degrees west.
But it is one time zone
earlier than London,
so it's in the same
time zone as Germany
and all the other cities
that are east of London.
And this is just for
convenience factor.
If you're traveling from one
continental European country
to the other, it
just makes sense
to have everything be
on the same time zone.
You get to work at
the same time sort of.
Pick up the phone,
call somebody,
you're doing business.
Now relative to
everybody else in Europe,
though, is the sun
setting later or earlier
if you're that far
west in your time zone?
AUDIENCE: Later.
PROFESSOR: Later, right?
So the sun is setting
later if you're there.
So if you're eating according to
the sun, not according to what
your watch is saying, but if
you're choosing to eat dinner
when the sun is
setting, when will your
watch say, oh my
goodness, it's really late
when you're in Berlin or
when you're in Madrid?
AUDIENCE: Madrid.
PROFESSOR: When you're
in Madrid, right?
So again, I'm not
saying that this
is the sole reason for
social behavior being
a little different on
the Iberian Peninsula,
since Portugal
also eats very late
and they're in the same
time zone as London,
but it could be a
contributing factor.
The sun is still up in the sky
when it's 5:00 PM in winter,
let's say, where in Germany,
it's set a long time ago.
So these are just little
things to keep in mind.
An easy way to calculate,
when is the solar noon,
you look at the
earth more or less
like we're looking
at this right now.
We have 360 degrees.
We divide that
into 24 time zones.
And then we say, OK,
about 15 degrees each.
And then we can begin
counting from there.
If in Boston, were
41 degrees north,
but we're 71 degrees
west, we can say,
OK we should be for GMT minus 5.
We should be at
around 75 degrees.
And so we're a little
earlier, so we do things
a little earlier around here
than what the solar noon should
be telling us to do things--
wake up a little earlier,
go to bed a little earlier.
And that's why students
are like, dang,
there's no night
life around here.
I'm not saying that's
the only reason,
but it could be a
contributing factor.
Whereas the opposite
happens when you're
far west in your time zone.
OK.
So again, just trying
to wrap our heads
around the solar resource and
around the world around us
so that we can answer that
little child in the shopping
mall when they come
with questions.
What are these?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Solar trash
compactors, right?
AUDIENCE: At the Student Center.
PROFESSOR: At the
Student Center.
Anna's Taqueria is
right over there.
Dunkin' Donuts is there, right?
So these are solar panels
mounted on the tops of those.
And what the solar is doing
is charging a battery inside.
Once the trash reaches
a critical lever,
a sensor is triggered.
It stops you from opening this
bin, and it compacts the trash
and then releases and allows you
to open and put more stuff in.
And what it does is it
minimizes the number
of times between trash pickups.
If labor is a large portion of
the cost of trash management,
of refuse management, then it
eliminates some of the labor,
transferring it instead
to the technology.
And so installing these
at the Student Center,
I had a little bit
of a pet peeve.
[LAUGHTER]
So you have angle
of the sun right
here, which we just walked
through, 18 degrees in summer.
And it just so happened
to work out that--
and these numbers
were approximate.
This was me going with my
kind of engineering sense.
That's about 45 degrees.
Count the number of paces.
Equilateral triangle.
Estimate the height of there.
But in the middle of summertime,
when you are at the solstice,
there is no so direct sunlight
hitting this trash can because
of that overhang way up there.
And it's not a problem for this
particular trash collector,
since those panels
are way oversized
for the amount of energy that
the trash collector actually
needs.
And there is a
fair amount of what
we call diffuse sunlight,
meaning sunlight being
scattered off of other things.
That's why this portion
of the image looks white.
It wouldn't look white if
there was no diffuse scatter.
It'd look black, pitch
black, if there was nothing
to scatter the light off.
Like an outer space, there's
nothing to scatter this way.
It looks like a black night.
But instead, there's a large
amount of diffused light.
There is some
sunlight reaching it.
And since the panels
are way oversized
and the system is
over-engineered,
it still manages to
acquire enough energy
to compact the trash.
And it doesn't have
a catastrophic stop.
But it was an
example of somebody
not really thinking much about
the direction or the angle
of the sun in the sky.
They probably installed
it sometime around March
when the snow started to melt
and the sun was right around
here.
And the angle was around
there, and it made it
into the trash collectors.
But as the summer came
along, it got shaded.
So it's something
to keep in mind when
doing a solar installation.
It is important to
calculate these things.
And I just pick out
once more example.
I'd encourage you
to walk through.
I was going to have that be a
small little in-class example,
but since we're
running short on time,
I'll just give it
to you like that.
OK.
Fixed versus tracking systems.
So if the sun is moving
as a function of season
and as a function of time
of day throughout the sky--
and we can see that
very nicely, again,
through our demo right here-- so
if the sun is actually moving,
one embodiment would
say, OK, I know
more or less what
the sun is going
to do as a function of season.
Forget the diurnal
variations, but just
the seasonal variations.
I know that the sun is going to
be on average somewhere around
here, somewhere
around my latitude.
So if I point my panel
at latitude tilt,
since this angle was--
what was it-- 41 plus 23.
This angle was 41
minus 23, so this would
be right around 41 latitude.
So if I aim my solar
panels at latitude tilt,
then I'm going to get, on
average, some pretty decent
power throughout the year.
I'll have a little
lesson in winter,
a little more in summer
because, well, just because
of the amount of solar
resources available.
But all in all,
I'll be all right.
At most, I'll be off
by 23 and 1/2 degrees.
You can do that.
And that's called
fixed latitude tilt.
And typically, you'll face the
panels south approximately.
We'll get to that in a minute.
It depends on local
weather patterns.
If you have fog in the
morning, for instance,
you want to face them
a little to the west.
But we'll face them south
and at latitude tilt.
Or we can decide,
no, let's actually
track the sun throughout
the sky throughout the day.
And so we'll start in
the east in the morning
and have it rotating
through on one-axis tracker
throughout the day.
Or we can have a
two-axis tracker where
it rotates to follow the sun
throughout the seasons as well,
a kind of a north/south tilt.
And that's what's
plotted right here.
This is a quick approximation
of the fixed one-axis
and two-axis
trackers for a given
system in Boston using a
simulation tool called PVWatts.
There's a link to that.
It's based on the National
Renewable Energy Laboratory
website.
There's a link to that
at the end of the slides.
But this shows you
the total system
output in terms of
kilowatt hours in terms
of hours per day.
I think, yeah, it's a little
bit of an odd units there
on the one-axis.
But it shows you
the relative gain
that you would get by
going to a one-axis
and then, finally,
a two-axis tracker.
So in many places,
it makes sense
to go to one-axis tracker,
since especially you broaden out
the peak near the
peak hours of the day.
And that's really good.
But not always does it
make sense financially
to go to a two-axis tracker.
You're adding another
motor onto that thing.
It's really not
gaining you that much.
Obviously, you have to
calculate it out yourself
for that specific location.
But by and large, a
generality, one-axis tracker
makes sense for a flat panel.
Now if you have a
concentrator lens in the front
and it has to be looking
directly at the sun,
then you're kind of forced
to go to two-axis tracker.
OK.
And there you have your
total system output,
which is just the integral under
the curve over the entire year.
So definitions-- I should
have done this before.
But direct sunlight,
looking directly at the sun,
and then diffuse sunlight or
scattered light coming off
of other things.
So diffuse sunlight would be
coming from the other angles
in other directions in the sky.
The direct sunlight
would pretty much
be at the sun plus or
minus a few degrees.
And we have different
ways of measuring
the-- this would be flat plate.
Up there on the upper left
it says, flat plate facing
south latitude tilt. Just like
we said, it's facing south.
In the United
States, that's good.
Latitude tilt, meaning it's
tilted at our latitude.
So if we go from the southern
tip of Florida and Texas
up to the northern
tip of Minnesota,
we'll be tilting
it more and more
toward the south like this,
going from Texas to Minnesota.
From Texas to Minnesota.
And so latitude tilt
facing south flat plate.
This is essentially accumulating
all of the sunlight, the direct
and the scattered light,
because it's all being collected
by the flat plate there.
This map, on the other hand,
is for a two-axis tracker.
And it's looking at the sun
plus or minus 2 and 1/2 degrees.
And so it's really only
picking up this right
here out of the sky.
And when it's sunny all
the time, you're golden.
You're tracking the sun.
You're actually
getting more energy
than you would if you
just at a flat plate
because the cosine theta angle
is changing throughout the day
if you have a flat plate.
When the sun is in
the morning time,
you have a flat plate like this.
So if my sunlight is
coming in like this
and I do cosine
theta of the angle,
I'm only getting a
very small amount
of the incident sunlight
projected onto this plate right
here.
If I was in the middle of the
day, now cosine theta is 1,
I get the full sunlight.
But if I have, for
instance, a tracker,
I would be able to face
this panel due east
and then track it
throughout the day.
And that's where I'd get this
additional energy boost here
in the mornings right there
from the tracking system.
So if I have a tracker,
I get a big gain
in the places that have
a lot of direct sun.
And if I'm only looking at
a very small solid angle
of the sky, if I'm only looking
at, say, this little portion
the sun, on cloudy days,
most of the sunlight
is coming off of the diffused
light, not from the sun.
If I have a flat plate, I win.
If I have a concentrator,
I lose on a cloudy day.
And so that's why, in some
of the regions of the United
States that are notoriously
cloudy-- I won't point
to any one in
particular-- it's actually
better for non-concentrating
solar in terms of total energy
output.
And in other regions
of the United States
where we have a
lot of sunny days,
you start having two-axis
trackers making sense.
And it's just really the
ratio of these two maps--
whoopsie-- this one,
which is flat plate,
and that one, which
is concentrator.
You see over here, we win if
we go for the concentrator.
And over here, we
get more energy out--
oopsie-- more energy out
if we use the flat plate.
Now that's just energy.
Obviously, cost and
economics factors
what it takes to install it.
OK.
And weather patterns, I
promised I'd get back to this.
Interesting to note that
for right near the equator,
we have this drop
of the insolation.
And there are these beautiful
maps put out by, again,
NASA Earth Observatory that
show you the cloud fraction
coverage of particular
spots around the planet.
And you can see that
right near the equators,
typically we have these
beautiful tropical forests.
The high cloud cover
in those regions
is blocking out some of the sun.
And likewise, you
can see the dichotomy
between Phoenix and Atlanta.
Same latitude again, but Atlanta
having a higher cloud coverage
than Phoenix and, hence, a
lower solar resource, a lower
insolation.
So you how all this
kind of ties together.
That's all predictable
in a sense.
This is unpredictable at a
local level for one system.
If the sun is tracing its
route through the sky,
and you have that
envelope function
that you've just spent so
much effort calculating out
with all your trig functions
in the computer simulation,
the code that you've
just been given here.
And now, a cloud comes
over, some random cloud
that was very hard to predict.
And you just have one panel,
one tiny little thing like this.
And the cloud goes over it.
Boom, all of a
sudden, you get a drop
in your instantaneous
power output.
Boom, drops again.
Another cloud, drops again.
And then a thunderstorm
in the afternoon.
So a meteorologist
could have told you
that this thunderstorm
was coming,
but a meteorologist
would be hard pressed
to be able to
predict the evolution
of a tiny little cloud
over your system.
And so the question is, to what
degree are these local weather
patterns predictable
and unpredictable?
And hopefully, some of
you, over this class,
will be able to help answer
that question by analyzing data
from tens of thousands
of systems that have been
installed throughout California
in local geographical systems,
for example, in the Los Angeles
region, San Francisco region,
and so forth.
If you start averaging
the curves, the energy
outputs as a function of time,
from a variety of systems
throughout a neighborhood,
you can probably average out
the small tiny clouds.
You probably can't average
out the thunderstorm.
But you probably could have
predicted that the thunderstorm
would've come along.
And so this is a hot area of
solar research at the systems
level.
It's trying to
understand, to what degree
are PV systems predictable?
To what degree can
the power output
of a PV system or an
ensemble of PV systems
be predicted in advance so we
don't wind up in a situation
where all of a sudden we
have this catastrophic drop
of a cumulative PV system
output of, say, 30%
and meanwhile, it's
a hot summer day,
everybody's air
conditions are going,
and we cause failure
of the power grid?
Kind of worst case scenario.
So this boils down to
intermittency with a short time
constants tend to
be less predictable.
Cloud cover.
And it's relevant for predicting
power supply reliability.
And the longer time constants
tend to be more predictable.
The diurnal or seasonal
variations-- and these
are relevant to calculating
total energy output annually.
And oftentimes, when
we just work off
of these long time constant
variability issues,
we're assuming we have
access to easy storage.
Right now, the solar
panels on top of my roof,
they're producing
in excess of what
we're consuming right now
because neither my wife or I
are at home.
And they're injecting
that power into the grid,
and the grid is serving
as our big battery,
as our storage unit.
And I'm riding free.
I'm a free rider right now.
I don't pay for that
service necessarily.
I do to NSTAR.
But they're not charging
extra for the service of using
the grid as my big battery.
Another thing to keep
in mind is that we're
calculating all this on
the basis of engineering
and scientific principles.
We're calculating
the solar resource,
which is a good,
important first step.
Now if we look at the
actual solar installations
by year and by country--
this is a big table,
but follow me on the two
underlined red lines here,
DEU, that stands for
Deutschland, Germany, and USA.
We'll see that Germany
has about seven times
more solar installed
cumulatively
than the United States does.
And yet, if we look at the
solar resource in Germany
relative to the US-- this is
average annual, same scale,
going from 900 to 1,200 kilowatt
hours per kilowatt per year--
we can see that there's a lot
more sun in the United States
than there is in Germany.
So there's something
else going on
than just the solar resource.
And that's economics.
That's why we talk about
the policy and economics
later on in class.
That's why we dedicate
a sizable portion later
on talking about that.
Lastly, our final
learning objectives
before we halt for questions
and for comments, we
need to estimate
the land area needed
to provide sufficient solar
resource for a project.
And this is really where
your homework picks up,
and we'll spend some
time in recitation
walking through this.
But it's important to
get your units right.
And so I want to do a
quick quiz right now.
Think in your minds
which of these properties
corresponds to which units
or are described by which
units over here on the right.
So do a kind of a linkage
in your mind one to one,
connect, connect,
without looking at your slides.
And then we'll do it
in three, two, one.
Those are your answers.
So the ones that
usually get confused
are power and energy,
kilowatts and kilowatt hours.
I'm not saying it's easy,
but the way to remember it,
the easiest way to
remember it, would
be to remember
that the power time
product is equal to energy.
So if you have
power instantaneous
energy burn rate versus
time, some plot that
looks like this as you take the
integral of that curve, that's
your total energy.
So in terms of units, current
voltage power and energy,
a hair dryer versus
a fridge, which
is more likely to
blow a fuse and which
blow your budget?
AUDIENCE: A hair dryer is
more likely to blow a fuse.
PROFESSOR: A hair dryer is
Why is that?
AUDIENCE: High voltage.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, high voltage.
Well, high current, really.
Because everything's
running 120.
It's a higher current.
It's pushing the wattage
up to around 1.5,
1.7, 1,500, 1,700 watts.
And so it's running close
to the 15 amp limit.
And the fridge,
on the other hand,
is probably an order
of magnitude lower.
But the fridge is
running all the time,
and your hair dryer is only
running a few minutes a day.
So in terms of blowing a fuse,
it uses a large amount of power
for a very short amount of time.
Whereas, the fridge uses
a small amount of power
for a long amount of time.
And the integral under that
curve winds up being more,
typically, then your hair dryer.
That's the total
amount of energy.
And you pay by the energy.
You pay by the kilowatt hour
to your utility company,
and that's why it
would blow your budget.
Yeah.
Oopsie.
So the numbers work out
to somewhere around 1
kilowatt hour per day for
the fridge and about 1/2
a kilowatt hour
for the hair dryer.
A kilowatt hour is
how much in here?
$0.18?
Most people pay about
$0.18 per kilowatt hour.
And so you can
calculate how much
it costs to keep things
running in your house.
Most of us don't usually
think about that.
And last, last, last, last
point, in your homework
assignments, you're going to
be asked to size out systems,
PV systems, photovoltaic
systems, in different parts
of the world.
And the easiest way to do
that is if we take a panel
and we say that this
panel right here
is rated at a certain
amount of power,
so under peak
illumination conditions.
When the panel is seated
at incident sunlight,
so the cosine theta term is 1,
and the incident solar resource
is 1,000 watts per square meter,
so around AM 1.5 conditions,
this panel right here would be
producing-- this one is tiny.
It would be producing
6 watts peak.
But most of these
panels over here
are producing somewhere around
a few hundred watts peak.
And so the panels are
rated in terms of watt peak
because the panel manufacture
doesn't know where
you're going to install them.
You could decide that
you're going to install it
in Alaska, in which case, it's
going to produce about half
the energy than if
you installed it
down south in the continental
US in, say, Arizona.
Maybe a third of the energy.
And so it doesn't
want to rate the panel
in terms of the energy output.
It's not going to
guarantee that you're
going to get a certain energy
output off of the panel.
But it will guarantee
that the panel
was rated at maximum
power of such and such
under standard
testing conditions.
Now that's good because
you can generalize it,
which you'll do
for your homework.
But it also has a downside
because standard testing
conditions aren't
real world conditions.
The panel isn't always
operating at 25 degrees Celsius.
The panel isn't operating
always at incident sunlight
normal, right?
And so the gap between
actually knowing
how much the panel is
going to output in terms
of its energy for
a specific location
and what our calculations,
the back of the envelope
calculations, will give us, that
gap is, from an economics point
of view, there's a lot of
money to be made there.
If you understand really well
how much of a given panel
will output, you can then
predict to a much finer degree
what you should be charging your
customer for installing panels
in a particular location.
So there's a lot of work
being done right now, more
on the business side
of pulling the systems
engineers along and
trying to increase
the accuracy of predictions.
And so with that, I will
leave off on this slide.
We can get to it during
recitation tomorrow at 4:00.
I welcome your questions here
at the front if you have any.
Otherwise, I'll
see you tomorrow.